huh interesting i just want to say
something very strange
uh no i'm not gonna say something very
strange i'm gonna say something that is
very strange to me
uh that i find fascinating about the
world of indie horror games so there's
this game called contempt that is
currently sitting at the top of the most
popular horror games now the funny thing
about contempt
[Music]
is that this game came out five years
ago but for some reason it's blowing up
right now which i think is cool there's
nothing wrong with that it's kind of the
weird cyclical thing about indie horror
games is that because sometimes there
are very indie horror not a lot of
people find out about them and then
someone will come along and find it and
it'll catch on for whatever reason and
then they'll play it and then it will be
popular again and i think that's very
cool because it is unique
to horror games anyway i actually was
queuing up to play that one but i i was
like man this seems familiar and you
know
this screen here was like oh yeah
i've played this before and no i'm not
going to play it again because i almost
feel like i've gone through this game
this might be the third time that i've
come across this game and been like have
i played this before and then i played
the same game again so i'm not going to
do that i'm going to play a game called
the elevator which i believe is made by
[Applause]
616 games you're not
you're not puppet combo you're different
okay
[Music]
either way i am down for all of these
very very
very retro scary games i think that
they're fun
i think they're dope as hell
so let's go to it new game are you sure
yes this is the elevator the elevator is
not working
[Music]
classic
oh
blast
[Music]
i love that the music i'm talking about
not not the lobby i'm not a lobby
enthusiast i'm not like
is that a classic 82 uh midwestern
looby lobby i don't know what i'm
talking about because i'm not like that
okay
fun
whoa
what
okay sit
tab to cursor up
get up get um guy god up
okay
hopes
okay
hosts good good great
great
okay
wow i really slammed on that bell okay
so i'm assuming that i'm working the
front counter
oh
okay this elevator is kind of weird
all right
i guess that's all i have to say about
that
um
oh
oh my god hi welcome hello how are you
welcome to the hotel how can i help you
sir welcome to the 82 looby lobby
how you doing
jacksepticeye oh
jesus
good evening sir i'm sorry
i'm staying in room 105. my name is
kareem musa
just a second sir i'll check
ah kareem musa got it
all right you can go up thank you
[Music]
to you too
have a good night
really appreciate your business
love your videos
oh my god hello what the hell what was
that
hello
who is there
[ __ ] the elevator is driving me crazy
okay
i feel like this isn't how elevator
should work but okay
[Laughter]
um
oh
well this is a lovely night to be a
lobby enthusiast hello lost child
have you seen this child
call
i have nothing to say about that lost
child
i'm not oh i can go outside
but only just barely
oh god sorry i was not playing with the
doors
welcome in
welcome to the 82 looby lobby how are
you doing
love the tie
darkiplier alan alonzo
please hello friend i stayed here this
morning i'm sleepy can i go to my room
just a second sir alan alonso
don't know how i know your name
alain alonso
yes you can go right up thank you and
good night
you too sir
you have a good one
you take care of yourselves
thank you for staying at the 822 looby
lobby
i'm not following you
i can't follow you i would never follow
you i'm not allowed up where the guests
are
[Music]
another guest another guest
hello
my name is markiplier welcome to the 82
looby lobby how are you doing ah
you were just cutting on trees were you
not congratulations thank you very much
for choosing us to be your place of stay
your face is terrifying
hi hey man i want to go to my room soon
i'm scott
just second scott t
[Music]
um
how do i say this scott uh scotman
scotty boy
your name is not homeless i'm sorry
go
you're lucky
you're very lucky
you're very lucky
where are you why hello
they need to fix the elevators soon yeah
that would be nice but also why is this
happening
i can't even call the elevator anymore
okay well so far so good
oh i can go in
hey
oh no wait a minute i didn't want to go
in there
hmm
oh my god
i think i'm going crazy working a bit
too hard you know what
you're right
but so long as i'm in charge of the
lobby
what is wrong with your body
hi
hi josh can i go to my uh am i josh i
don't know
i'm too tired
hello mr salzano just a minute
puck scale salzano all right
go on up good night and good work friend
thanks pal sorry about the comments on
your
wonderful physique i more said it like
what is wrong what is oh wrong with
your body in the way that everyone
else's body's wrong and yours is perfect
what
what wait whoa whoa whoa whoa wait wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait whoa whoa hey hey hey who's here
hey hey
you guys saw that right there was
somebody in the camera and
hi
okay um am i just hot what hmm
there's a bit of a problem there
i gotta get the phone
hello hotel 616 josh how can i help you
good night josh's detective hoffman i'm
gonna alert you to a murderer on the
loose goodnight detective a killer good
night killer on the loose we're going
all the hotels in the area he's a
dangerous guy the victims are all
children
my god can you tell me more about them
we have a description of the suspect a
tall bald bearded man my god can you
tell me more about him we have a
description of the suspect a tall bald
bearded man
thanks for the warning detective can you
tell me more about him i'll keep an eye
out thanks for your attention josh good
night how
did i say my name i did didn't i
well
um
again
this is strange right here that's that's
that's strange anyway a tall bearded man
oh good
[Music]
i'm in the elevator
definitely nothing scary about this
okay
nothing scary at all
i think i'm going crazy i'm working too
hard why why do i think that
what
crazy why
crazy why crazy why why crazy that crazy
i don't like that
i don't like that
i don't like that
i don't like this elevator i don't like
the elevator at all i don't like this
elevator
i don't like you none
don't like you
why
stop what are you doing
oh my god i'm gonna need to go josh if
anyone looks for me let me know why
would people look for you you're not a
tall bearded bald man
oh my god
who do we know
that's tall bearded and bald
the notorious third host of the
distractible podcast
i don't want to name names but let's see
and pull up a photo of a mr wade barnes
hmm
awfully suspicious don't you think
maybe it's just a coincidence or
maybe not
maybe not
okay but probably okay
anywho
oh gone are we
interesting i guess i'll just pop a
squat
right
okay fine i'll i'll bite i'll bite i'll
bite i'll bite
i'll bite
anything for me over here no just a
normal ass elevator
[ __ ] okay
you gonna play with my feelings
are you tall and bald are you tall and
bald well you're the person from the
picture
you're the person from the picture oh
you're the missing person from the
picture you're the missing picture
person why
are you
oh oh
oh no
okay all right i'm not going to pay that
any mind oh
no
mr vasquez oh no
oh no
oh
god
hi
i'm freaking
[Music]
out okay i just got [ __ ]
everything is fine
i didn't see anything strange i didn't
see anything strange at all
nothing strange happened i didn't see a
dead child in the elevator
and that dead child didn't guide me down
the hallway and i certainly didn't see
mr vasquez strangling that very child
who was dead
in the room in front of me and then i
wasn't magically transported back down
to the lobby the looby lobby of the
hotel 616.
and now i'm just sitting here
or i was and have been and currently am
and nothing weird is happening
should i go upstairs check out nope
salzano matches the killer's
characteristics
i'll notify the police
will i
will i notify the police
detective osman how can i help you hi
detective this is josh from the front
desk at hotel 616. hi josh do you have
something important for me
this guest hero matches the
characteristics of the assassin he has
just left the hotel thanks for the info
i'll send a friend over to check it out
a friend
a friend
he'll send your friend not a not another
police officer you're going to send your
friend
act cool hey
what is up
mr
whatever your name was
[Laughter]
if it isn't my favorite patron hear the
looby lobby salzano did something happen
josh you look very nervous oh nobody
it's okay how's your walk invigorating
but are you sure it's okay
you're sweating
it's okay don't worry i'm just tired
i think you're hiding something
aren't we friends i'm not hiding
anything i already told you everything
is fine stop crying it's my privacy shut
up you're a weirdo
um
all right
[ __ ] that was close he's very suspicious
he is very suspicious what's the
dripping
why is there so much dripping
oh no
that's not good blood is dripping from
the top of the elevator
okay well this uh oh
no
oh no
oh boy that's um
man i feel like i should have an opinion
about that
my god this scene will never get out of
my head
[Music]
so uh
what what do i
what do i do about
what what what do i do about that should
i leave i feel like i should leave
i feel like leaving's a good idea
[Music]
um
[Music]
well whenever that friend wants to get
here would be super chill
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well um that got me
hopefully it uh didn't get you if you
didn't get got let me know down in the
comments below that way we can together
know who was not god and who was god if
you got got then say you got god in the
comments and if you didn't get got say i
didn't get god no one got me i was never
got in the first place stop asking if i
was god in those exact words that way
we'll know for sure who was and was not
god thank you for all being here with me
as i got god
and of course given that i got god i
will comment that i got got if you want
more scary games they're linked in the
description below if you want to follow
the description of the murderer you can
find a mr wade barnes on the
distractible podcast available through
the link in the description below
thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you